foreign
there are many strong moments in a show
but in a battle series few are as
important as the rage moment these are
scenes that sometimes define character
at other times simply Mark a shift in
the overall tone of the series it also
leads to a lot of moments of ass kicking
which get forever immortalized in the
hearts of the fandom today we're
celebrating some of those notable rage
Moments by counting down 10 of my
favorite ones from newer anime taken
from shows that have aired between the
years 2020 to 2022 here are rage moments
that are simply memorable and or bone
chilling for me
first off we have red versus bond rude
[Music]
made in Abyss continues its role into
the new decade considered one of the
best anime to come out of the modern era
it seems that the show never took its
foot off the gas delivering us Banger
after Banger of anime material I've
talked about how one of the villains
Bond drude had such an imposing first
impression he didn't have to be a
physical Abomination to incite horror
and fear in his appearance however dark
reg sure gives him a run for his money
and it's a complete departure from the
sweet naive robot boy that we've come to
love they completely flipped the switch
here an anime dark red looked every bit
as menacing as the manga counterpart
[Music]
coming up is Luffy's elephant gun
against kaido
the kaido fight truly is a clash for the
ages we've got so many memorable moments
that will leave a lasting impact out of
one fight alone here's one moment that
you might have thought I overlooked
which is the elephant gun scene we've
already seen Luffy at his most angry but
in terms of Rage moments that happen
during a tough battle there's little in
the way of coming close to this as far
as Luffy's concerned it really helps
that the anime team really emphasized
the power and the emotions he had
boiling within him as he descends to
strike down kaido with elephant gun the
speed lines the close-ups on his face
and the sheer power welling up in that
moment such is truly the magic of anime
in its ability to make the fans feel so
emotional
and if that prepared you enough for some
hot blooded action how about checking
out our sponsor for this video dungeon
Fighter online dungeon Fighter online is
a multiplayer RPG that combines some of
your favorite elements from those good
old hack and slash roguelike games
choosing from 16 unique Fighters or who
can Branch out to multiple classes and
start slaying enemies on route to The
Ultimate Prize and if you start now
you'll arrive just in time for dfo's
next major update with this new update
DFO introduces ispins the usurp lands
promising a challenge more difficult
than anything veterans have ever faced
before the game's extremely fun and I
help you get started with it by
Redeeming the code in the description
you'll receive a whole bag of goodies to
help you out in starting your adventure
in addition to the usual consumables
that you get you'll also have a cool
Avatar set that will help you get
started in customizing your character
the time is now if you're looking to hop
in and join the fun click the link below
to download dungeon Fighter online and
join an ever-growing Community that's
bound to get even bigger and stronger
Mob vs deutero is up next on the list
a pissed off mob is a rather rare sight
but not one that we haven't seen before
once again that form of our protagonist
rears its head in the climactic Battle
of mob psycho's second season this fight
is a great way to end the world
domination Arc a collision that sees
both combatants reach their respective
100 modes the build Up's great and I
could talk about the fight in itself and
its implications to the story soon but
we're here for the rage moment and boy
did we get one seeing mob in full and
bridled fury like this is a treat for
anime fans who just can't wait for our
hero to go all out against dastardly
villains all it took was toichiro
roughing up Mom's friends in a way that
we haven't seen them before and we're
all treated to a bloodthirsty expression
that we haven't seen out of mob before
that smile that crazed look drinking in
mob psycho fans this is a mob who's out
to hurt people this is a mob ready to
flex his powers on this villain Who
Dares threaten him and his companions
the Eye Candy of a fight that follows
makes this shift in character worth it
on the contrary Our Stars no stranger to
being angry at his enemies but this
moment against Dante is something else
laid Black Clover is truly amazing we
got fights and conflicts on a scale like
we've never seen before and we've got
Peak after showing off his destructive
powers in scenes that gets fans off
their feet like this Dante taking on the
black balls gave us a glimpse of astha
at his most destructive and it's a treat
to see the initial attacks made by Asta
were already filled with power and
emotion behind them the huge attacks
hits that laid waste to the environment
around them were already a thing of
beauty but things go Full Throttle when
Dante makes his counter-attack seeing
his comrades get attacked was enough to
put Aster in a rage mode unlike anything
we've seen before and hearing him scream
his heart out here gave me some chills
people back then often memed about our
Stars shouting in early Black Clover but
when utilized the right way our star's
rage feel shouts gave us this moment to
remember
ah
next up we look at donjiro versus [ __ ]
clanjiro versus [ __ ] started out a bit
slow not in terms of intensity but in
the way that the two fighters spent some
time sizing each other up each move was
deliberate yet filled with power however
that wouldn't last long as danjiro
starts feeling the weight of the
destruction around him he's not the most
wrathful character around but you really
know [ __ ] pushed a button too many when
we finally get to see this danjiro face
the next phase of the fight then
proceeds with danjiro fighting in a much
more brutal manner than before it's
enough to get him to match [ __ ] and man
handle the demon on route to what looked
like a massacre darky's attacks all look
feeble in front of this danjiro alas it
wouldn't last and we proceed to the next
part of the fight which involves nezuko
so if this is danjiro using his rage to
temporarily break his limits and locking
the road to a new burst of power that we
haven't seen him utilized before surely
one of the highlights of this long
battle that defines the Entertainment
District Arc
but we're not stepping on the brakes now
not just yet as we proceed with Yuji
versus mahito
Mito is one of the strongest villains
introduced in season one it's just that
Gojo makes all these curses look so weak
but Mahi though provides a much needed
hit Back to Reality by upping the threat
level of the enemies in Jiu Jitsu Kaizen
even nanami found himself struggling
against mahito when it's all said and
done but we're here to talk about one of
the key scenes before that pivotal
moment yuji's fight against mahito the
part where it's Yuji taking on Mai
though gives us a new perspective on
Yuji it's the most rage field he's ever
been in the series so far and you can
feel the tension At His Highest
throughout this moment despite mahito
taking everything in stride you've got
to admit he got one hell of a trashing
two in the end it's nice to see this
fight drill it in that synchronizer
villain through and through he's not
just any convenient anime power-up that
our hero has access to it does feel like
an offshoot of hollow Ichigo in a way at
first but when it comes to execution I
think that makes Jiu Jitsu Kaizen cool
with an identity of its own it gives me
some gone and kintoki flashbacks if you
get what I mean just look at Eugene
black and white and tell me doesn't look
like them in that moment or maybe mob
since we talked about mob psycho just a
little while ago too
[Music]
we have Endeavor versus high end as the
next moment
with someone as driven and fiery as
Endeavor it would be a complete shock if
you didn't have one of those rage
moments at all and he did in what people
consider his signature fight the white
people often remember him for yes the
one against high-end nomu for a lot of
people this is a fight that showcased
endeavor at his Peak Powers how powerful
would he be going all out but for me
it's also the fight that unleashes the
pent-up anger that he always kept Under
Wraps as shocking as it sounds like
endeavor's not the nicest guy or dad
around but he never had an outburst like
this in the series no and it's that
unshakable drive that Unstoppable desire
that he derives his power from the fight
also serves as Endeavor burning away his
past and moving forward as he himself
said it also ends up giving us a
finisher that sent chills through mha
fans spines Endeavor never looked as
cool as he was before this fight and
this only likely solidified his standing
in fans favorite characters lists
and we have chainsaw man taking up the
next spot on the list
chainsaw man has surpassed expectations
it's a bit too early to tell but as of
now I'm so glad that as far as the hype
was concerned chainsaw man didn't
disappoint one bit it's every bit as
dark brutal and over the top as people
expected it to be and it didn't take too
long to start showing off what it's all
about with dengie's moment in episode
one it's not often you see anime depict
fights in such a violent and unhinged
manner that chainsaw man did it the
violence really helped the scene make a
statement when it comes to representing
denji's mental state in this moment here
you have a killing machine laying waste
to everything in sight and the fans are
loving every moment of it overall this
is a great scene that sets the tone of
what chainsaw man can be moving forward
it's every bit of what fans wanted and
expected and I don't think the anime
team will start pulling punches moving
forward it's the opposite in fact
prepare for more rage blood and
brutality
no no
shinoy Curry watching you are you in one
of the many chilling moments in Bleach
Yamamoto unleashes his rage on driscolla
Yamamoto has always been the definition
of tranquil Fury he's not loud or
bombastic completely different from the
likes of kenbachi however deep within
lies a merciless and Unstoppable monster
he's always shown to be firm and
Resolute but we rarely see him actually
unleash his rage in a way like this not
even in the fight against Eisen seeing
this Quincy use his most trusted
subordinates Bankai however was enough
to unlock that side of him that one
thought they'll see again even in the
face of the Bankai he merely held
everything before unleashing everything
in a pent-up Inferno destroying the
faker and giving a proper farewell to
his most loyal companion the whole voice
acting and solemn turn before shifting
to Pure hype really elevated this moment
from the manga counterparts so much such
is the beauty of finally getting anime
adaptations of cool scenes that you've
read from manga
thank you
[Music]
but for something less unless the top in
terms of violence something grittier
more rooted in reality is Mikey
I get the oversized weapons the crazy
blood splattering or the superpowers if
you want some good old hand-to-hand
combat and intense gritty shows of
camaraderie Tokyo Revengers might just
be your jam the doorman gang find
themselves in a pickle against the
dominating Valhalla it's an all now gang
war that had Mikey on the ropes as
shocking as it may be as we'll find out
however there's no Force more powerful
than your leaders pure unrestrained rage
despite taking some big hits that would
have knocked someone out all it took was
a little shaken off of cobwebs and
triggers to get Mikey into this mode
resulting in a kick the New Gen anime
fans will never forget not trying to
discredit the Valhalla not everyone can
push Mikey to the brink of the mindset
but let's just say that he's not caught
Invincible Mikey for nothing everyone
learned a lesson that day one they gave
enough Credence to that nickname
[Music]
if you're still here then thank you for
watching and if you haven't done so
please like And subscribe I upload
videos multiple times a week and I hope
that I can see you again the next time I
upload and don't forget to check out
dungeon Fighter online the links in the
description fun times away those who
dare take the chance I'll be waiting for
you that's it thank you and I'll catch
you later